Bitte schön.
Guten Tag. Ich heiße Dr. Korkmaz. Ich bin die Savender auf dieser Station.
Ich würde mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch durchführen. Sind Sie damit ein Verstanden?
Ja, bin ich.
Bevor wir über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden sprechen möchten, ich ganz schnell Ihre personische Daten aufnehmen. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Harald Noske.
Harald Noske.
Könnten Sie Ihre Nachname langsam bestabieren?
Ja, N, U, S, K, E, Noske.
Noske. Okay. Herr Noske, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 58.
Okay. Und wann sind Sie genau geworden?
Am 16. September 1964.
Okay. Herr Noske, wie viel wiegen Sie und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich wiege zur Zeit 74 Kilo.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,81 Meter.
Okay, Herr Noske, wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, ich fühle mich seit einer Woche ziemlich schwach. Es geht mir nicht gut.
Ich kann jetzt nur noch wenig Schritte gehen und auch Treppen steigen fällt mir schwer. Dann bekomme ich keine Luft mehr.
Und mir ist dann noch schwindelig. Also es geht mir nicht gut.
Okay. Sie haben bei besonders Hochgehend ein Atemprobleme.
Ja, bei Treppen steigen, ja.
Und seit wann haben Sie genau diese Beschwerden?
Seit einer Woche geht es mir eben nicht gut. Da fühle ich mich sehr schwach.
Aber insgesamt muss ich sagen, geht es mir schon seit einigen Wochen nicht so gut.
Da hab ich einen guten Appetit.
Ich glaube, ich habe auch etwas Gewicht verloren.
Okay. Und fühlen Sie sich piblich?
Ja, ich habe in den letzten Tagen häufiger gemessen und da habe ich so zwischen 38 und 38,7.
Okay. Und haben Sie irgendwelche Knoten in Ihren Achselhöhe oder Haltsbereich oder Leistungbereich bemerkt?
Also am Hals, glaube ich. Der Hals ist irgendwie, ich trage sonst gerne auch mal ein Hemd so enger Kragen.
Und das geht gar nicht mehr. Und ich glaube, der Hals ist etwas dicker geworden.
Haben Sie Schluckstörungen?
Nein, Schluckstörungen habe ich nicht.
Manche beeindruckt, dass, wenn ich auf der Seite liege, auf der linken Seite, das ist dann auch da auf der linken Seite im Bauch, im Oberbauch ziemlich drückt.
Und haben Sie Schmerzen im Oberbauch oder im Unterbauch?
Schmerzen nicht.
Schmerzen. Okay.
Haben Sie Nachtschweiß oder Schütterfrost?
Ja, Nachtschweiß habe ich schon. Ich habe zuerst gedacht, das liegt an dem heißen Wetter.
Ich habe Tagschwitze, aber dann war es jetzt ja einige Tage etwas kühler und da habe ich Nachtschweiß gehabt.
Okay.
Herr Mossem, leiten Sie unter Herzrasen oder Herzklaufen?
Also ich glaube, mein Herzschlag ist etwas schneller geworden in letzter Zeit, mein Puls.
Ich habe manchmal messig meinen Puls, der war sonst immer so bei 70 und jetzt ist er eher Richtung 90.
Okay.
Und hatten Sie Probleme bei Husten?
Nein, nicht.
Husten nicht.
Oder haben Sie in Ihrem Bein geschwollen, dicker geworden bemerkt?
Dickere Beine?
Ja.
Nein, auch nicht.
Okay.
Und brauchen Sie zwei, könnten Sie Flaschen liegen?
Flach liegen im Bett.
Flach liegen, ja.
Das konnte ich noch nie. Also ich brauche immer Einkissen.
Aber mehr auch nicht, aber Einkissen brauche ich.
Einkissen, okay.
Ich möchte eine kurze Zusammenfassung machen.
Sie haben seit einer Woche schwach und haben Sie…
Seit einer Woche habe ich eine Schwäche.
Ja.
Schwäche und haben Sie Atmenprobleme bei Treppen laufen.
Treppen hochlaufen.
Vielleicht bekomme ich schlecht Luft, ja.
Und Sie haben bemerkt, dass Ihre Halsbereiche eine dicke geworden.
Ja, ja.
Okay.
Und in linksseitiger Oberbau, was ist das Problem?
Ich verstehe das nicht ganz genau.
Ich habe viel so einen Druck.
So, dass ich denke, ja.
Keine Schmerz, aber es gibt dort ein…
Druckgefühl.
Druckgefühl, okay.
Okay, ich verstehe jetzt.
Okay, Herr Noska.
Haben Sie Probleme bei Wasserlassen oder Stullgang?
Nein.
Ich muss in der Regel einmal in der Nacht auf Toilette Wasser lassen.
Aber das muss ich schon seit einigen Jahren.
Okay.
Und ich bin mal beim Urologen, aber der sagt, das ist alles in Ordnung.
Das ist auch gut.
Und sind Sie schwindelig?
In den letzten Tagen, jetzt seit einer Woche, ist mir häufig schwindelig, ja.
Ja.
Okay.
Und manche Arbeitskollegen haben auch gesagt, ich sei in letzter Zeit so blass.
Blass, blass geworden, okay.
Und haben Sie noch andere Hautfarbeänderungen bemerkt?
Haut? Nein, nein.
Okay.
Herr Noska, leiden Sie an irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen wie Bluthochdruck
oder Brutzzuckerkrankheiten?
Eigentlich geht mir ja ganz gut.
Ich habe etwas hohe Blutfettwerte und hohes Cholesterin.
Und da nehme ich eine Tablette ein, seit ungefähr fünf Jahren.
Was nehmen Sie ein?
Moment, das habe ich ja aufgeschrieben.
Das heißt Simvastatin 20 steht dahinter.
Da nehme ich eine Tablette abends.
Abends, okay.
Und gibt es andere Medikamente?
Noch etwas?
Nein, sonst nehme ich keine Medikamente ein.
Okay.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, ich bin schon mal operiert worden als Kind an einem Mandeln.
Operation und an Blinddarmoperation habe ich gehabt.
Am linken Unterarm hatte ich einen Bruch.
Beim Fußballspielen wurde dann eine Platte eingeschraubt mit Schraubung versehen.
Die wurde aber dann nach anderthalb Jahren wieder entfernt.
Das war so vor 25 Jahren.
Wie viele Jahre haben Sie gegessen?
25, vor 25 Jahren.
Und wann war die Blinddarmoperation?
Da war ich vielleicht 11 Jahre alt.
Und wann war die Entfernung?
Ein bisschen jünger war ich dann, 9 oder 10.
Ich hatte oft Eidrige Angina.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Okay, Herr Noska, sind Sie vollständig geimpft gegen Corona?
Ja, ich bin gut geimpft.
Ich gehe ja regelmäßig auch zum Hausarzt zur Gesundheitsuntersuchung.
Das letzte Mal war das allerdings vor einem dreiviertel Jahr.
Und da war aber alles in Ordnung.
Ich brauchte da keine neuen Impfungen.
Okay, sehr gut.
Herr Noska, ist Ihnen irgendwelche Allergie oder Unverträglichkeit bekannt?
Nein, ist mir nicht bekannt.
Okay, rauchen Sie Herr Noska?
Nein, ich rauchen nicht. Ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Sehr gut. Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke mal Bier, aber auch nicht jeden Tag.
Also vielleicht in der Woche, vielleicht 3 Flaschen pro Woche.
3 Flaschen pro Woche.
Okay.
Und nächste Frage ist eine Routine Frage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay. Herr Noska, lebt Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, der Vater lebt noch. Der ist 86 Jahre alt.
Der hat hohe Blutdruck.
Und auch hohe Blutfette.
Und auch Medikamente. Aber der ist eigentlich noch ganz gut.
Die Mutter ist mit 81 Jahren an Brustkrebs verstarben.
Okay, es tut mir sehr leid.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe ein Bruder.
Der ist 56 Jahre alt.
Der hatte vor einem Jahr eine Gallenblasen-Operation wegen Steiner Gallensteinen.
Okay.
Herr Noska, wir sind fast fertig.
Ich möchte nur ein paar Prada über Ihre sozialen Lebens stellen.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Hausmeister an einer Schule.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, bin ich.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe auch Kinder, zwei Kinder, 30 Jahre alt und 27 Jahre alt.
Die sind aber gesund.
Aber die leben nicht mehr bei uns.
Die sind in einer anderen Stadt.
Okay. Aber Sie sind gesund.
Leiden Sie unter Stress bei der Arbeit?
Nein. Die Arbeit ist manchmal anstrengend.
Aber direkter Stress?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Schreiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ja, ich habe in letzter Zeit immer, bin ich zweimal in der Woche gejuckt.
Und einmal in der Woche Tennis gespielt.
Aber in den letzten Wochen habe ich das nicht mehr gemacht,
weil ich so müde war und zu schlappen.
Okay.
Herr Noska, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen meinerseits gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder fragen?
Ja, ich frage mich, was kann das sein,
was ich habe, warum ich mich so schlapp fühle?
Ja, ich verstehe Sie, Herr Noska.
Ich habe auch eine Diagnose zu stellen.
Wir müssen unbedingt ein paar diagnostische Massnahmen durchführen.
Und nach der Ergebnisse sprechen wir wieder.
Gut. Das können wir so machen.
Okay. Nehmen Sie ein Klass, warten Sie mal, ich komme durch.
Ja, danke.
Herr Noska, haben Sie Brust- oder Brustschmerzen beim Treppensteigen?
Nein, keine Brustschmerzen. Nein, das tut mir nichts weh.
Okay. Sie haben erwähnt, das war Gewichtsabnahme.
Wie viel Kilo haben Sie abgenommen?
Ja, so innerhalb der letzten zwei Monate, acht Kilo.
Okay, danke schön.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ja.
Bitte.
Hat jemand mit Ihrer Umgebung die gleichen Situation?
Nein, nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Herr Noska, leiden Sie unter Übelkeit?
Ja, der Appetit ist ja nicht gut.
Wenn ich dann so großes Essen sehe, Fleischportionen und so,
dann wird mir schon manchmal etwas übeln, aber erbrechen und so muss ich nicht.
Okay, so wie ist Ihr Stuhl?
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhl? Nein.
Ist Ihnen ein schwarz Stuhl aufgefallen? Nein, der ist normal gefärbt.
Okay, sehr gut.
Hatten Sie in den letzten sechs Monaten öfter Infektionen, Erkältung oder Grippe?
Ja, ich hatte so, dann war das vielleicht im Mai, da hatte ich mal ein Infekt husten
und auch etwas Temperatur damals für fünf, sechs Tage.
So etwas kannte ich eigentlich nicht zu der Jahreszeit.
So etwas habe ich bisher, wenn dann überhaupt immer nur im Winter gehabt.
Waren Sie damals, wurden Sie damals stationär behandelt oder am Blätter?
Nein, da war ich kurz beim Hausarzt und der hat mich dann eine Woche krankgeschrieben
und danach habe ich aber wieder gearbeitet.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Sie haben auch gesagt, in den linken Oberbau Druckgefühl,
sind diese Druckgefühle strahlen irgendwohin aus?
Nein, nein, auf jeden Fall von dich.
Sind sie immer da oder?
Ja, die sind eigentlich immer da, aber ich merke es besonders, wenn ich auf der linken Seite liege,
dann rückt das irgendwie noch mehr.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Okay, bei Ihnen, in den letzten sechs Monaten, wie viele Kilogramm?
8 Kilogramm.
Ja, in den letzten zwei Monaten, 8 Kilo.
Okay, sind bei Ihnen z.B. eine verschiedene chronische Krankheiten,
Lebe-Krankheit oder?
Das ist mir nicht bekannt und bisher waren die letzten Untersuchungen.
Oder Nieren- oder Lungen-Krankheiten bekannt?
Die letzten Blutergebnisse ist aber links vor einem Dreivierteljahr gewesen,
beim Hausarzt, die waren alle in Orten.
Wie sind Sie beim Ihren Bauch und Ihren Beinen,
eine geschollene Bein, zum Beispiel?
Das hatte der Kollege schon befragt, ich habe keine geschollenen Beine.
War sie Ihnen letzte Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, ich war im letzten Jahr nicht im Ausland.
Tam es bei Baguette-Verletzung zu blaue Flecken?
Blaue Flecken?
Ja.
Nee, ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Am Ende, ist der Hals-Schwellung schmerzhaft oder?
Nein, nicht schmerzhaft.
Aber irgendwie ist der Hals dicker, habe ich den Eindruck.
Wenn Sie zum Beispiel Alkohol-Tierinkern-Geschicht noch etwas schmerzen,
haben Sie bemerkt?
Ja, ich trinke jetzt ja nicht so viel Alkohol, ich trinke keinen Schnaps,
ich trinke keinen Wein, ich trinke ja nur mal Bier und dann immer nur eine kleine Flasche.
Da habe ich aber keine Schmerzen.
Könnten wir als erstes jetzt anfangen?
Entschuldigung, haben Sie eine Hautveränderung bemerkt oder verändert sich Ihr Stimme?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Entschuldigung, gibt es etwas, was diese Beschwerde verschlechtert
oder verändert?
Ja, ich sagte ja, wenn ich treppen steige, die Luftnot, ich komme schnell Luftnot,
ich kann höchstens ein Stockwerk langsam hochgehen und dann muss ich aber Pause machen.
Das war früher ganz anders, da habe ich Sport gemacht und da war ich fit.
Dankeschön.
Ahmet, bitte schön.
Okay.
Guten Tag, meine Oberarzt.
Ich habe einen neuen Patient.
Ich möchte ihn Ihnen vorstellen, haben Sie dafür kurz gesagt?
Ja, habe ich.
Harut Nosher, 58-jähriger Patient, er kann heute seit ein paar Wochen aufgetretener Fatih zu uns kommen.
Entschuldigung.
Ich denke nicht, ich werde erstmal Hauptbeschwerden, Bispne und Vertigo und Fiber.
Ein paar Woche bestehende Fatigue zu uns.
Früher hat der Patient
schreibt regelmäßig.
Ich denke nicht.
Ich erst mal hauptschwerden,
bisbne und vertigo.
Ich denke und Fibar.
Danach.
Also, Noske klagt bei der Aufnahme
über seit einer Woche bestehender Schwäche.
Einer Woche.
Aber insgesamt schon seit einigen Wochen
fühlt er sich nicht gut.
Also seit einer Woche geht es ihm gar nicht gut.
Da, der auf Not und so weiter.
Aber gut.
Machen Sie bitte weiter.
Okay.
Normalerweise
trägt er regelmäßig Sport,
aber einige Woche
fühlt er
körperliche Schwäche und
Fibrik.
Er hat, er gab an,
dass er ein paar Mal
ihre
Fibar gemessen
und ungefähr
durchschnittlich 39,5.
Und er hat
ein, bitte
38,
38 bis
30.
Ich habe gesagt durchschnittlich.
Nein, aber 38 bis
38,7.
Genau.
Nicht mehr.
Okay.
35 ist zu hoch.
Entschuldigung, was ich habe gesagt.
Sie haben 39,5 gesagt.
Entschuldigung.
Okay.
Ich meine, ich habe 30,5.
Berichtet über febrile Temperaturen
zwischen 30 und 38,7.
Ja.
Okay.
Und es passieren auch andere Symptome,
die er schildert?
Ja, er hat
Gewichtverlust ungefähr
in zwei Monaten, acht Kilo.
Und
er hat
Atm-
Dispene bei Treppe steigen.
Belastet.
Dispene.
Erklagt.
Ja, belastet Dispene.
Und er hat bemerkt,
er hat in
Halsbereich
Ödemme oder
eine Knoten vielleicht bemerkt.
Er hat im Halsbereich
eine Schwellung bemerkt oder eine Verdigung bemerkt.
Ja.
Und
auch er hat
in
linkseitiger Überbau
Durke-Fühl bemerkt.
Okay, ein Druckgefühl.
Ja.
Als
in
in vegetaritiver Anamnese klackte er über
Nachschweiß,
Inapetanz,
Vertigo
und
Seine Freunden
gab
seine Freunden
Erwähnen, dass er
belastet geworden.
Ja.
Das heißt, vielleicht er hat
Anämie.
Das kann eine Vermutung sein, ja.
Ja.
An-
Leider er die Hyper History
compensate
Er wurde
25 Jahre wegen einer Linkunterarmfragtur operiert.
Aber alles war komplikationlos.
Er ist nicht raucher, er trinkt drei Flasche provokte Biya.
Im Familie Anamnese hat sein Vater Arteriele Hypertoni und Hypercholestronomie.
Seine Mutter ist mit 81 mit einem Mamakarsinom verstorben.
Er hat auch einen Bruder erleidet, Kolelithiasis.
Der Bruder ist vor einem Jahr scholezistektomiert worden.
Er ist Hausmeister verheiratet, hat zwei gesunde Kinder.
Mein Verdachtdiagnose ist eine Lymphoma.
Er spricht für einen Lymphom, Fatig, Geruchsverlust, Fieber, Nachschweiß, Bäsymptomatik.
Im linken Oberbauch liegt ein Tumor.
Was für ein Organ liegt im linken Oberbauch?
Er erklärt vielleicht dieses Druckgefühl, das der Patient beschreibt.
Ist es differenzial diagnostisch?
Es ist differenzial diagnostisch.
Vielleicht ein anderer Karcinom, ein anderer Körperteil,
eine Bösartik-Tumor.
Was spricht jetzt nicht unbedingt für eine Herzinsuffizienz?
Er hat keine Gewichtszunahme, keine Zythianose, eine Bäsymptomatik,
eine Abnahme, Nachtschweiß, die berühmte Trias.
Damit bin ich einverstanden.
Ihre Anamnese haben Sie sehr systematisch erfasst.
Sie haben nicht direkt bei den Gewichtsverhalten nach Gewichtsabnahme klar gefragt.
Sie haben sich ein bisschen verklausuliert und wurde von den Kollegen nachgefragt.
Das ist ein wichtiger Aspekt, eine starke Gewichtsabnahme innerhalb von zwei Monaten.
Sie haben sich in der Vorstellung beim Oberarzt klar benannt und haben sich bemüht,
viele medizinische Fachausdrücke umzusetzen.
Da achten Sie darauf, gerade im Anfang, lieber einfachen Satz.
Herr Noske ist 58 Jahre alt und stellt sich vor, wegen einem seit einer Woche deutlich reduzierten Allgemeinzustand.
Er fühlt sich schwach, hat klagt über eine schnell auftretende Belastungsdisziplin,
zum Beispiel beim Treppensteigen.
Was vorher nicht bekannt ist, Herr Noske hat regelmäßig sonst Sport,
was er in den letzten Wochen aber nicht mehr gemacht hat, weil er sich zu schwach fühlt.
Also ein Prozess, der schon seit einigen Wochen geht und der jetzt aber so stark schlecht geworden ist,
dass er einfach in die Notaufnahme kommt, weil er wahrscheinlich eine hochgradige Anämie hat
und aufgrund dieser starken B-Symptomatik.
Sie haben, denke ich, die Fachbegriffe gut gebracht.
Bei den Gallensteinen, denken Sie dran, der Bruder hatte eine chulizistektomie.
Sie haben richtig benannt, Tonselektomie, Appendektomie, OP oder Osteosynthese im Bereich des Unterarms,
unfallbedingt vor 25 Jahren.
Hypercholesterinämie haben Sie benannt, Mama-CA, Hypertonie, bin ich alles mit einverstanden.
Also aus meiner Sicht denke ich, ich könnte Sie am 5. August diese Prüfung in aller Ruhe machen.
Vielen Dank.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Der Patent hat gesagt, seit einer Woche keine Sportmorgens.
Das heißt Leistungsfähigkeit.
Die Leistungsfähigkeit hat in den letzten Wochen schon er berichtet über eine Leistungsabnahme in den letzten Wochen.
Sport ist ihm nicht mehr möglich.
Seit einer Woche hat sich der Allgemeinzustand weiterhin verschlechtert.
Ich denke, wir sollen am 1. August eine Fatigue nicht sagen.
Ich weiß nicht, bis für diese Patienten die Symptomatik.
Aber man kann ja schon, ich würde sagen, der Patient berichtet über eine deutliche Leistungsminderung in den letzten Wochen mit einer weiteren Verschlimmerung seit einer Woche.
Und damit haben wir schon mal das benannt.
Das muss man nicht unbedingt mit Fatigue bezeichnen, sondern ich würde erst mal sagen Leistungsminderung.
Das ist durchaus ein medizinischer Begriff.
Das darf, denke ich, auch in der Prüfung gesagt werden.
Leistungsminderung.
Wichtig ist uns im Zusammenhang schnell auftretende Belastungslistpnö.
Belastungslistpnö.
Das merkt der Patient, Treppensteigen fällt ihm schwer.
Sonst ist er gejockt und hat Tennis gespielt.
Da hat er keine Probleme gehabt.
Und jetzt merkt er, ich komme gar nicht mehr richtig die Treppe auf.
Noch an der Frage, Kollegen.
Gut.
Ich habe eine Bitte, dass wir uns nächste Woche, kann ich nicht am Donnerstag, können wir am Mittwoch machen?
Okay, Mittwoch, wie viel Uhr?
18 Uhr.
18 Uhr, okay.
18 Uhr, Mittwoch.
Dass Sie sich das bitte merken, weil Donnerstag...
Ja, okay, ich werde einen E-Mail schicken.
Dann wünsche ich Ihnen eine erfolgreiche Prüfung.
Vielen Dank.
Gute Gelassenheit, gute Nerven, das ist dann alles.
Dann wird es gut werden.
Und Ihnen anderen eine gute Zeit auch, einen schönen Abend
und bis nächste Woche, Mittwoch.
Vielen Dank.
Tschüss.